saviez vous que des séances de sport
pourrait être prescrite sur ordonnance
prochainement l'agglomération a rejoint
le réseau sport santé sur ordonnance
lancée en 2012 par le docteur alexandre
feltz à strasbourg réseau qui compte
déjà une soixantaine de communes membres
au niveau national les acteurs du projet
sur saint quentin
elles doivent être encore ciblé qu'il
s'agisse des médecins généralistes ou
encore des associations
du côté des patients on sait que ceux
atteints d'une affection de longue durée
d'une maladie respiratoire par exemple
seront concernés ce dispositif vient
d'être lancé en fin de semaine dernière
et c'est est une nouvelle fois au
vélodrome
je pense que ça va se passer comme dans
toutes les autres villes c'est à dire
que il faut mobiliser les médecins
généralistes parce que c'est eux qui
sont en contact avec la population va
définir le type de maladie diabète
cancer hypertension maladies
respiratoires stabiliser et puis on va
créer un lieu de coordination peut-être
ici ou dans une dans un autre centre où
les éducateurs vont recevoir les
personnes malades
l'agglomération s'engage à faciliter la
coordination entre les différents
acteurs de ce de ce dispositif notamment
pour la communication notamment pour la
mise à disposition de ressources
humaines pour la gestion du dispositif
pour permettre éventuellement aussi de
mettre des locaux à disposition et pour
permettre de gérer au mieux avec les
ressources humaines nécessaires
le dispositif santé sur ordonnance